good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight so you can question
whether joe biden actually got what's
the number 81 million votes in the last
presidential election and actually later
in the show we will
but even if you accept that there
actually were people who voted for joe
biden voluntarily
it's hard to believe that many of them
got anything like what they expected in
return for their votes
joe biden not to be dark about it just
to be honest joe biden has turned out to
be an unparalleled disaster it's not an
overstatement in fact it's a generous
assessment
our country has never seen anything like
what joe biden has done
barely 15 months into his first term as
president joe biden has crashed the
stock market provoked a food shortage
opened our borders to millions of
illegal aliens presided over historic
rises in murder inflation and drug ods
as well as a corresponding plunge in
overall life expectancy
and then because all of that wasn't
punitive enough for a country as racist
as ours he dragged the united states
into an entirely pointless war with a
nuclear armed power on behalf of a
corrupt foreign government that once
bribed his drug addicted son that's all
real joe biden did all of that
and those are the big easy to measure
crimes he has committed we spend
virtually every night cataloging some of
the rest shuttered schools permanent
looting latin american levels of wealth
inequality tampons in the boys bathroom
seven dollar a gallon gasoline
unprecedented race hatred homelessness
mental illness suicide
and above it all across the pacific
ocean a chinese government that's
laughing out loud as we destroy
ourselves for no reason
that's some of what joe biden has done
so far
he promised a return to normal he's
delivered war and economic collapse
joe biden is old enough unfortunately
they almost never certainly be held
accountable for any of what he's done
but his party should be
how will any democrat outside west
hollywood ever get elected in this
country again
in a fully functioning democracy that
would be an honest question
but biden has a plan
torque up the fear ban complaining
criminalize the opposition
just 24 hours ago joe biden the
president united states told us that
people who don't support him are the
single biggest security threat that
faces this country not al qaeda not the
chinese military not the mexican drug
cartels not even russia which we are
told daily is the wellspring of all evil
no
you
you're the biggest threat because you
don't vote democrat
as joe biden put it quote this maggot
crowd is really the most extreme
political organization that's existed in
american history the most extreme the
worst worse than the klan worst of the
nazis worse than the anarchists who
murdered an american president worse
than anyone ever that's you
you're an existential threat to the
country you were born in
it's hard to believe joe biden said that
but he did say it and of course some
people believed him
here's what the supreme court looks like
tonight you'll notice the riot grade
security fencing around the building why
is it there well it's there to protect
the justices inside from the mobs that
joe biden has incited with the
demagoguery you just heard
samuel leto is a 72 year old legal
scholar whose views would have been
considered ordinary mainstream maybe
five years ago
now according to joe biden he is a
dangerous extremist he's a member of a
movement more threatening than any
political movement in american history
what's the result well today
alito had to cancel a public appearance
because there were too many threats on
his life
each one of those threats is in fact a
threat to us and our country
you don't want to live in a country
where supreme court justices cower in
fear for their lives if they reach the
wrong conclusions that's the definition
of a failed state
turns out we have a justice department
that exists to prevent things like this
from happening that's the whole point
but under joe biden the doj is too
beholden to the mob to say a word about
it you can't offend antifa
they're a vital constituency here's the
attorney general merrick garland
appearing today to tell us what he's
worried about most watch
consistent with the president's
executive order on tackling the climate
crisis at home and abroad we are issuing
a comprehensive environmental justice
enforcement strategy communities of
color indigenous communities and
low-income communities
often bear the brunt of the harm caused
by environmental crime
pollution and climate change
well of course the greatest threat is
global warming which by the way is
racist like so many other weather
patterns
that's what merrick garland is most
afraid of tonight and of course in order
to fix global warming which is
existential whatever that means you're
gonna have to hand merrick garland and
joe biden a lot more power over your
life sorry that's the only solution much
more on that to come
but for now here's what you should know
merrill garland didn't even mention the
threats the physical threats to this
country's highest court because those
threats come from the left and therefore
aren't really threats see how that works
you're about to see more of it
a left-wing activist group has now
published what it says are the home
addresses of justice's amy coney barrett
john roberts samuel leto brett kavanaugh
clarence thomas and neil gorsuch quote
we must rise up to force accountability
using a diversity of tactics explains
the group's website a diversity of
tactics what are those well you can
imagine they already include disrupting
catholic church services
not a big deal in order to change the
supreme court decision that's not an
attack on democracy or anything mayor
caron is not concerned
now if someone were to vehemently
criticize oprah that'd be different we'd
have to hold a press conference and call
on the national guard
but conservative supreme court justices
yeah they deserve what they get
and so of course under these conditions
violence is already beginning abortion
lunatics just vandalized a church in
colorado the same thing has happened to
a pro-life counseling center in portland
in los angeles demonstrators threw rocks
at cops for some reason what did they
have to do with it who knows
war on the system and they injured one
of them went to the hospital but merrick
garland isn't worried about any of that
his fellow democrats support that
they're calling for it they long have
here's chuck schumer from two years ago
threatening mob action
if any supreme court justice were ever
to get out of line watch this i want to
tell you gorsuch i want to tell you
kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions
you will pay the price
really these are people with lifetime
appointments so how exactly could they
pay the price we can't vote against them
what can we do we can hurt them
we can harass their families we can make
it impossible to live in this country
through threats of violence quote you
won't know what hit you said the thug
from new york apparently they're about
to learn what's going to hit them
remember when liberals used to oppose
violence they did give peace a chance
it's hard to believe there was ever a
time that that was true maybe they were
just pretending in any case they're now
for it violence is their religion here
and abroad
you're seeing it
on display
right in front of you whether you've
noticed or not in eastern europe
so rather than trying to save the
civilian population of eastern europe
joe biden is pushing for a hot war
against russia in fact he's already
engaged in a hot war against russia and
so are we whether we knew it or not new
york times just ran this headline quote
u.s intelligence is helping ukraine kill
russian generals oh no big deal
according to the paper quote the united
states has provided intelligence about
russian units that's allowed ukrainians
to target and kill many of the russian
generals who've died in action in the
ukraine war according to senior american
officials so they're bragging about it
and not just that nbc news reports that
biden officials are also bragging about
helping to shoot down a russian
transport plane carrying hundreds of
russian troops and then tonight
since the theme here tonight the
administration is saying out loud that
actually it helped sink a russian
warship
now why are they doing this
and more baffling why are they taking
credit for it in public
why would you tell people you're doing
that there's only one reason because you
want war with russia
not a fake war not a proxy war but a
real war with thousands of american
troops trillions wasted and many dead
that's what war is and war against
nuclear-armed countries is hard to
imagine there's never been one
there's no reason to have a war like
this there doesn't need to be a war like
this we wouldn't be having one if joe
biden didn't want one but biden wants it
he's doing this on purpose we're not
imagining that he's telling us what he's
doing we're just ignoring him many
democrats are telling us what they're
doing here's biden ally congressman seth
moulton of massachusetts saying so out
loud on fox on monday watch
if they wrap this in the senate uh with
a ukraine funding and a coven funding
you guys okay with that congressman
moulton
look i'm going to support it because
it's the right thing to do for ukraine i
mean obviously there's a lot of politics
involved and there will be domestic
debates here at home about all their
policies and whatnot but at the end of
the day we've got to realize we're at
war and we're not just at war to support
the ukrainians we're fundamentally
at war although it's somewhat through a
proxy with russia and it's important
that we
really we're at war did you know that
did they text you to let you know
because
wars tend to escalate
and wars that are existential for one
side in which the leader of a country
feels he may die if he loses tend to
escalate very quickly obviously
seth mullen isn't worried it's just
important that we win he tells us we
really who's we and important to whom
exactly is there anyone outside
washington
who wants a real war with nuclear-armed
russia
who exactly is seth moulton talking
about when he says we
we were wondering that we watched biden
yesterday he traveled to alabama and he
visited the only constituency in america
that longs for war with nuclear-armed
russia and that would be his donors
he toured a lockheed martin plan and as
he did biden boasted that we're sending
so many weapons to ukraine
that mothers in the united states are
naming their children after lockheed
martin's missile systems watch
but we built the weapons and equipment
that helped defend freedom and
sovereignty in europe years ago
that's true again today those javelin
missiles like the ones manufactured
right here in pike county
they're highly portable they're
extremely effective
against a wide range of armored targets
they can hit targets up to 400 meters
away
in fact they've been so important
there's even a story about ukrainian
parents naming their children not a
child
a newborn child javelin or jebel means
not a joke
it's a joke this little joke about
weapon systems you know it used to be
when american presidents talked about
killing people the first thing they did
was make certain it was absolutely
justified we've been invaded pearl
harbor 9 11.
this is an entirely voluntary exercise
and the second thing they did
was attach some gravity to the idea of
people dying because when people diet
sad they leave behind
spouses and parents and siblings and
children death is sad acknowledge that
they don't joke about it joe biden
considers that an uplifting story joe
biden is demented and he's dangerous and
so are the people who work for him
that's true sorry to say it out loud but
it's real this country needs sane
leadership and it needs it immediately
it cannot come too soon pray the
midterms for fair subscribe to the fox
news youtube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
tucker carlson tonight